Music [MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello everyone, my name is Fred Chung, the Google developer's instructor Hello, my name is Fred Chung, developer advocate at Google.
This is the first episode of the two series of DevByte series. This is the first of a two-part DevByte series covering
To introduce the Android media router framework in the support library.
Enjoy it has become thin common for users on tablets and smartphones today
Video and music have become very popular to stream movies or play music from their tablets or smart phones.
For example, at home in the living room, for instance,
Maybe you will use some external speakers, you may want to make use of those external speakers
Or support a Wi-Fi monitor to enjoy the content in your personal media library or Wi-Fi displays to enjoy your personal library of media content.
Android provides a flexible media routing framework for apps (app). a flexible media router framework for any apps
Enable them to cast media content to support its external devices for playback.
In this section we will discuss media routing In this episode, we are going to talk about the media
This is the application's media layer router, which is a mediation layer for apps
Used to deliver media content to supported devices to cast media content to supported devices.
The path to the device is called the paths to these devices are known as media routes.
There are many APIs provided in the upper media routing. At a high level, the media router
Used to generate the delivery button offers APIs to render the cast buttons,
Discover and select media routes, discover and select media routes, [? preread ?]
Ability and the capabilities of the routes, and control
Intent-based protocol-controlled remote playback via an intent-based protocol.
In the next paragraph we will discuss media routing providers In the next episode, we are going
In the next paragraph we will discuss media routing providers to explore media route providers, which
That is a package of Android and additional media is a component that encapsulates the underlying
The component of the underlying communication between devices is communication between Android and external media devices.
Device manufacturers can implement their own MRP (Media Routing Provider) Device manufacturers can implement their own MRPs
Make it a media route on Android in order to publish themselves as media routes on Android.
For example, Chromecast (Google TV Stick) is in the Google Cast SDK For example, Chromecast has implemented
Implemented a media routing provider that allows applications to use an MRP in the Google Cast SDK through which apps can integrate with.
Use this architecture program basically with this architecture, apps are essentially
Decoupled from underlying transport implementations
Decoupled of the media routes.
Now let's look at some implementation details. We're going to look at some implementation details.
But before I start, I want to explain But before doing that, I wanted to call out
The media routing framework we are talking about now is in the support class library that the media router framework we are focusing here
That means it is compatible with is in the support library, which means that it is backward
Android 2.1 and above compatible with Android 2.1 and above.
At the same time, don't let the media routing framework and media routing in the Android framework and let's not mix it up with the media router in the Android
Messed up the framework.
To initiate media routing, the user when initializing media routing
The user clicks on the Cast button and clicks on the Cast button, which typically
Generally displayed on the ActionBar is placed on the action bar.
By button the user can Through the button, the user would
Select a player to disconnect to be able to select a media route, disconnect from the route,
Control remote playback and other control playback on a connected route, and so on.
Add a Cast button to the ActionBar via One way to add the Cast button in the action bar
Add action provider manual item it points to is add an action provider manual item pointing
Media routing action provider class to the class media route action provider.
Then in the menu initialization code, Then, in the menu initialization code,
Set the action provider menu item associate menu item action provider
Associated to a media route selector object with a media route selector object.
The router is essentially a Filter (filter) that filters media routes. Route selector is basically a filter for media route capabilities.
The application can specify the category of media routing An app can specify categories of media routes and points
Then automatically select the available player it can work with.
This framework uses the selector The framework uses the selector to present
You can only show the user the appropriate playback route only the appropriate media routes to the user.
For example, if an application requests a video streaming function, For example, if an app asks for video streaming capability,
The system will not provide the user with audio media routing the system won't present audio-only media routes to the user.
There are many predefined categories There are several predefined categories,
Including remote control of audio and video streams including remote playback, audio streaming, and video streaming.
Of course, the type of customization can also be defined by MRP, custom ones can also be defined by the MRPs.
Now let's look at the initialization of the media routing object Let's have a look at the initialization of the media
This object maintains the entire state of the media route, which maintains the overall state of media routing.
Once you've gotten a reference to the singleton media router when you reference a single media routing object
You want to register the media route callback, it will object, you want to register the media router callback, which
Providing events on media route changes,
For example, routing custom adjustment volume such as route selections, modifications, and volume changes.
You can find out more about the API reference for details by using the API guide.
The specific callback flag in this code, this this snippet, the particular callback flag
Will cause the system to immediately search for available media routes. The system to immediately discover available media routes.
Keep in mind that route search may contain network calls. Keep in mind that route discovery may involved network
So when calling calls, and therefore you should be
After searching the route, don't forget to diligent in removing a callback when the route discovery is
Delete callback no longer needed in your app.
Another point to note is that if you use Fragment, I also want to point out that if you're using fragments,
Another option is to use Media Route Discovery with Media Route Discovery.
Fragment gives the same hook for the callback registration, which giv es you the same hooks for callback registration.
Once the user selects a media player, Once a media route is selected by the user,
The application can remotely control the play on the terminal. The app can begin issuing remote playback controls to the endpoint.
The instructions are asynchronous, The indications are asynchronous,
So consider that the media terminal may be remote. It makes sense considering media endpoints may be remote.
The media routing framework defines the media router framework defines
An intent-based protocol for basic playback controls based on the intent protocol
For example, play pause or jump to such as Play, Pause, or Seek.
You can find your definitions of the action and extra parameters in the Media Control Intent class.
The definition of actions and additional parameters in the media control intent class.
This code shows This snippet illustrates the indication
The basic remote play command first uses the category remote value where the basic remote playback where first, it constructs an intent
The appropriate action constructs a with proper action in category values
Intent and media [URI] as well as the [? URI ?] of the media.
Then check if the selected route can handle that request. Then then checks if the selected route is capable handling such request.
Finally start Intent It finally fires off the intent.
The framework will report the results through the asynchronous callback framework
The result of the invocation via the asynchronous callback.
There is also a good practice where not included in this snippet,
But it is not good practice to account for situations where
That is, if remote playback is not available, remote playback is not possible, in which case
Your program should switch back to local play your app should fall back to the local playback.
Ok today, we mainly from the perspective of application casting (That's it for an overview of media router
Introduces an overview of media routing from an app casting prospective.
If you have time, you can check out the documentation and examples in this section, Have a look at the docs and samples.
You can also keep an eye on the media routing provider and stay tuned for the episode on media route providers.
Thank you for watching the happy Thanks for watching and happy casting.